[Music]
hello I'm Dr Peter Saruman and I'm a
world famous urologist think about what
your ears do for you every day they let
you hear things they show off your
jewelry they even hold up your
sunglasses unfortunately until now
science has provided no way for us to
thank our ears until now because now
there's the Ralph report the Ralph
report is a daily podcast that will let
your ears know how much you love them
Monday through Friday they'll feel
appreciated as they get to listen to
Showbiz news crazy funny weird news
celebrity interviews sex stories Sports
stories music movie reviews and much
much more I gotta tell you this Ralph
Garmin guy is nuts
[Applause]
and the unbelievable part is the Ralph
report costs you just three dollars a
month that's right three dollars a month
you can get the the Ralph report Monday
through Friday for a whole month for
just three dollars do you know what you
usually get for three dollars crap like
this the funny old nose and glasses bit
not even a whole gallon of gasoline for
three dollars you get a couple cheap
disposable lighters oh [ __ ] is this real
gasoline
your starving years at the
ralphreport.com
it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
[Music]
this Hollywood Babylon
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
foreign
[Music]
my god I've always wanted to do this it
is Saturday night in Atlantic Highlands
New Jersey
[Applause]
so let's Babble the [ __ ] out I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Ralph Garman
hey kids
because he owns the movie theater
nice place you got here friendly people
I like that's really [ __ ] uh kids
welcome to the very first uh pot live
podcast we've ever done at smodcast
Castle Cinemas man and uh
and it stands to reason that uh it would
be uh me and Ralph doing Babylon because
uh that was the birth of our live
podcasting uh concern I've done like a
lot of podcasts with Scott but we you
and I were the first ones that did it in
front of people which sounds exactly as
filthy as ever
now we also podcasted together too and
ever since the beginning how about we've
been doing the show at 12 years or
something 12 years now ever since the
beginning we've talked about doing a New
Jersey Babylon
um one in the area and then when we got
smodcast on Leonardo the thought was
like well there's only 50 seats we'll
have to charge people 200 a ticket yes
in order to get Ralph out but when we
got Spa Castle Cinemas it was suddenly
like oh my God [ __ ] like we got 200
seaters and that's that's like the
Improv back home yeah so uh we have a
permanent home for uh shows out here uh
hopefully you all spread the word and
Ralph will be out maybe over every every
other month or something well I don't
see why not as long as people want to
see it
who am I to say no to these people
absolutely
um before we go further I'll make a
drink yes before we go further I'm gonna
make a drink is that what you're gonna
say please yeah Ralph needs to get
[ __ ] lubricated
um we had a very busy day kids uh we
spent uh most of the morning uh making a
music video with the artist logic had a
lot of fun we shot here in this very
[ __ ] room I was here 7 A.M shooting
some [ __ ] then we uh went to Quick Stop
and Shop there I was wearing the [ __ ]
Silent Bob costume again Jay was here
Brian and Jeff
um so we spent all day shooting we
wrapped like only a couple hours ago and
I tell you all this not to brag
although nobody clapped
[Applause]
a lot of [ __ ] you work hard yeah I do
thank you
uh so in any event
um it's not about me so much as uh from
early in this morning uh I we've been
taxing uh Dr Josh Roush who played B
camera on the entire [ __ ] shoot so
LeRon who shot clerk three was on a
camera Josh was shooting B and rather
than prepare for tonight which took a
[ __ ] lot uh the lights that are on us
right now were hung last night by Josh
all the [ __ ] wiring work the fact
that we have two microphones that plug
into the sound system here is because
Josh ran 16 [ __ ] channels and stuff
like that we only needed two but
whatever [ __ ]
um so did Ernie what is it so did Ernie
so did Ernie yeah enough 32. oh Ernie
wants credit [ __ ] you Ernie
absolutely Ernie a smart Castle keeper
Ernie O'Donnell of course ladies and
gentlemen give it up for him
um
but after all that shooting today and
after all that prep last night and stuff
then we were like uh Josh Mount the show
real quick and stuff so um Paul a lot of
Kinks to pull this off but we're
normally used to doing it at the Improv
where it's turned out yeah um and for us
it's easy we get here and we're like
let's [ __ ] do a show we uh somebody
has to figure out how to do the show and
he figured it out right before the show
[ __ ] began because he had such a
Harriet schedule so please give it up
for Dr Josh
and Josh of course will also be running
sights and sounds during the show as
well as if that wasn't enough just
making it happen so we thank you Josh we
appreciate it and we got we're on the
big screen for those who aren't uh here
with us just listening we're on a giant
screen here at uh theater one in smart
Castle cinema this is the theater where
uh my father took me to see
um Blade Runner wow uh this is the
theater where uh my ex-girlfriend Kim
Locker gave me a hand job to Labyrinth
this is the theater well hold on one
second
Kim's here
did I say hand job I meant handshake
was she imagining you were David Bowie
I don't know we'd have to ask her and
[ __ ] but I was imagining I was David
Bowie yeah everything I've done I've
done but you know what you're the Bowie
guy
yeah I don't know that song so well do
another Bowie then
Ground Control tonight
that's not Labyrinth at all no no it
isn't
um also in this theater I've told this
story before uh I went to see Friday the
13th maybe a new beginning one with a
heavy set dude who eats chocolate and
[ __ ] like that that's an important part
of the [ __ ] story all right fair
enough just laying it out there so uh
it's me and uh who is it uh Ernie
O'Donnell uh Mike bellicose and we're
sitting with Danny hapstack and uh at a
point in the movie that character the
heavyset dude eating the chocolate and
[ __ ] like that was on screen and in a
Pitch Perfect quiet [ __ ] moment uh
Danny have sex with other Ed haps that
goes it's [ __ ] Kev Smith
now if you had said that now people
would be like Kev Smith he made [ __ ]
yoga hosers hahaha everyone knows who
Kevin Smith is back then three people
knew right so it was okay but those
three people looked at me and they're
like you poor son of a [ __ ]
but you're that guy
you got the pity nod I did but that
happened in this [ __ ] theater and it
took me
30
seven years
but
um I've now made it that that that half
step could never come into the theater
again
you're going to put his picture up at
the box office
don't let this bad boy in
never to be admitted
no you let him in when he's at the
movies and then and then you tell
everyone else in the movie theater to
say something really shitty about him
during the movie and everyone will turn
to him and just shake their heads and
feel bad for him oh my God Revenge yes
yes a dish best serve cold holy [ __ ]
that's Insidious thank you
I'm evil on my best days
um how have you been I ain't seen you in
a minute I've been on the clerk's uh
convenience tonight have you been
touring with clerks three I don't know
if you knew this but I think I would
have seen something about that on social
media if that was the case it's been
absolute [ __ ] Bliss man uh being out
on the road uh with the flick the
audiences have loved it we've yet to
encounter an audience it's like go [ __ ]
yourself most people are just like oh
[ __ ] us It's A Hard movie not to love
there's a lot of feelings in that film I
agree so it's been absolutely uh
wonderful a lot of folks here uh have
seen the flick on tour a lot of we
started the tour here in uh New Jersey
at the count basic theater over in Red
Bank and stuff so a lot of folks have
seen the flick already and it's just
been so nice you know I I'm used to last
few years making a thing and the people
in this room like it and then everyone
outside this room is like what happened
to you you piece of [ __ ]
um it's nice to make something where
it's not there's still people like what
happened to you piece of [ __ ] but
generally people seem to be vibing with
what we were selling with the movie in
the in the in the real world on tour
it's an incr it's a self-selecting group
right because you people are overpaying
to see the movie right so at a certain
point people who hate you are never
gonna [ __ ] go so the room fills up
with people who are like like your [ __ ]
so you get a room full of [ __ ] people
who are like-minded is I've been
watching it for 22 [ __ ] uh nights and
this is the closest I get to a Marvel
movie
that's true because the people in the
room all know the collective ongoing
story right and so like you know there
are times I don't I I my career is thus
is such that like I've always looked at
some people and been like oh that looks
cool I wonder what that'd be like to do
and then I do it like [ __ ] film came
from seeing Richard Lake later and cycle
be like that looks cool I wonder what
that'd be like to do and I tried a
podcasting game from listening to Howard
Stern for years I was like that's
[ __ ] cool I wonder about people like
sit around talk to your friends and feel
like that be honest and stuff
um comic books like oh [ __ ] I want to be
like to be Neil Gaiman and I don't get
to be any of these people but I get a
taste of what it's like to do that thing
that they do so you know I see that all
the Marvel movies I love them to death
never once think about making them never
once think about being the person behind
them and [ __ ] but love the collective
moments I've been in the audience for
[ __ ] like when
you know Captain America catches Thor's
[ __ ] hammer and everybody goes
[ __ ] ape [ __ ] even like a grandparent
and [ __ ] like that look I know what that
[ __ ] means he's worthy you know
it's just like oh you're in church like
it's almost like going to a cathedral
where everybody is in agreement
on what raises the spirit right and and
so it's beautiful and I've always felt
like oh man I've never wanted to make a
Marvel movie but for that moment like
that would be worth the ride to try to
do it just to have that moment where
everyone's on the same page and [ __ ]
like loudly of [ __ ] applauding and
[ __ ] and on the convenience tour there
are at least 18 of those moments
throughout the night where it's just
like that's as loud as one [ __ ] Thor
when Captain America caught the hammer
and that's as close as I'll ever get to
it I'll never have that moment myself
but in my world I can fashion that
moment in their world that moment
happens on 5 000 screens simultaneously
four shows a day around the world for a
good three four six months straight
right for me it happens in a packed
[ __ ] room of 12 to 1800 people only
50 times ever but I'm there for each one
and it's unbelievably [ __ ] validating
and [ __ ] honestly I'm shouldn't tell
these people they could keep the [ __ ]
money man oh nice could you wait till
the end of the show
oh my God it's so [ __ ] Blissful man
so you have you you went to the premiere
yes which and premieres suck but for a
premier and you know they were in L.A
which is a calloused City full of people
who think they can all make a movie
better than the guy they're watching
make a movie it was a great reaction
given the circumstances of being in that
town people really liked it I would
agree that being said it was tepid at
best
um except when I came on people really
liked that part crazy like oh my God
k-rock's Ralph Garmin yeah
um they fired him they said after that
there is thank God he's still alive I
thought he killed himself man what
happened to that guy
thank you thanks for that memory by the
way
you're the king you're the king of
Atlantic Jersey [ __ ] okay we're on
that's right
a whole largest radio Market in the
country thing was just a way to get to
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
because my grand scheme I had a whole
[ __ ] a whole last 30-year career just
to buy this place
and now they can never not let me show
my movies here that's right
um all right you ready to do a show
before we get into the show real quick
if you don't mind yeah since we talked
about Josh at the outset yeah and we're
in a movie theater yeah besides being
the greatest guy in the world and
helping us out on everything that we do
and everything that you do yes Josh has
also uh written and directed his own
film
I don't know if you guys knew this or
not Kevin's a producer on it
Josh was kind enough to ask me to be in
the film and it's getting ready to start
being shown I think December or
something they're going to start having
screenings soon and live uh the amazing
Australian girl who opens their tour
every night and you see running around
working her [ __ ] ass off constantly
is the star of the movie she is indeed
and she's brilliant um which is so weird
because I think of Liv most days as the
person who sits on stage holding up
cards to tell me to stop talking during
the Q a yeah she holds up a series of
cards and the first one is like 10
minutes left then five minutes left then
stop talking and then five minutes over
10 minutes over and then seriously stop
talking there's one that says please
stop talking now
so um she's a wonderful tour manager but
she's an artist if you ever saw um
Hollow Ian the shirt that we did in that
how what was holidays horror film
um she was one of the girls in and stuff
and she's the star of Josh is moving
absolutely [ __ ] wonderful she sings
in it she acts in it she's great and so
we thought since we're in a movie
theater what the hell we'll Premiere the
poster for wrong reasons tonight to give
him a chance to see what it looks like
and so Josh if you'll do if you'll throw
it up there there it is
congratulations Mr Roush
that's uh James parks next to her in the
mass yes who is with us in Red State
exactly Michael parks's son and Liv is
in it and you can't tell from the poster
but I'm also
[Laughter]
well we talked about the poster and I
was just like leave Ralph off man let's
sell the [ __ ] Sizzle and [ __ ] yeah
all right thanks
um Alan Amato who did our show art and
stuff he shot that he's brilliant he's
been brilliant photographer that's a
great poster congratulations pal well
done sir wrong for you guys
um
wrong reasons gonna debut at the this
mod Castle Film Festival which happens
uh November 30th to December 4th is that
right Ernest thank you November 30th to
December 4th and I think we have a
outfit you should come out for that
you're in the [ __ ] movie
one person one person wants to be back
it's the maid at the motel where I'm
staying I left a big tip
yeah come back
uh yeah and then we're doing a screening
in LA in La too in December I think
December 7th as well yeah
um all right so so anyway it's enough
about [ __ ] Josh Jesus [ __ ] he's great
enough for a lot of Josh maintenance
yeah let's talk about some folks here in
the theater who've come particularly
long distances or celebrating special
occasions with us tonight it's a segment
we call the shout outs
around so get your [ __ ] cows
get your [ __ ] out
[Applause]
[Music]
first time in my own theater
with a microphone yeah
fair enough
you can do that with that mic safely
because that's yours we've been all
around the world with this show and
you've been sticking microphones in your
mouth without knowing where they've been
or who's had them previously totally yes
but now I'm relatively sure that
12 teenagers handled this before I put
it in my mouth that is one of the things
I [ __ ] love about this theater what's
that um so you know I bought uh me and
my friends me and Ashley and Jeff and
Ernie uh and Tony all bought this place
Tony was the guy that reopened it when
it was closed after kova and kept it
going as Atlantic movie house and then
we all kind of came together and bought
the [ __ ] place now upstairs there's
an apartment right and uh right now you
know whenever I come to Jersey I
generally stay at Marriott Courtyard or
Oyster Point or something but now it's
like oh [ __ ] I could stay above the
movie theater and it seemed like a cool
idea yes when we were in process of
buying it it seemed you said scene
seemed
it is a cooler oh good in practice it
has been unbelievably [ __ ] amazing
man the first night that I stayed
upstairs uh they told me they're like
we're gonna turn the alarm on at night
for the movie theater and [ __ ] I said
well I can't go downstairs like you go
downstairs you go to the lobby and go to
theater one and stuff but if you go down
the hallway or the other hallway is
going to trigger the alarm oh man so I
was like I'll never do that okay so I I
it was three in the morning uh once you
take a [ __ ] no toilet paper upstairs
that's like mental note go to Bed Bath
and Beyond and so um I was like [ __ ]
what do I do and then I was like there's
a whole ass [ __ ] set of bathrooms
downstairs Kevin so I went downstairs
and I didn't bring my phone to turn the
light on and [ __ ] because I didn't think
all the lights would be off and all the
lights were off and I opened the
bathroom door it was Pitch [ __ ] black
was trying to feel around put my hand in
the urinal and [ __ ] and I was like that
ain't it and so I was like oh you know
[ __ ] maybe the lights are on in the
women's room oh boy and I went to the
women's room and that's when you enter
the hallway and it tripped the [ __ ]
alarm and it was a screechy alarm it's
no silent arms
and I just quietly went back upstairs
and closed the door sat on my bed and
waited for the police to arrive just
rocking back and forth yeah I was like
why did I do that I shouldn't have went
poopy
as God's punishing me I'll definitely
buy more toilet paper definitely
definitely buy more toilet paper
like nuts but I looked out the [ __ ]
window from upstairs and sure enough the
[ __ ] cops showed up this ain't Los
Angeles where they deal with real crime
and [ __ ] they're like an alarm 10 cars
show up and [ __ ] like that and every
cop's got a boner
they're like let's shoot Hollywood
come on out Hollywood
um it was uh that was a great night but
here's the best thing that [ __ ]
happened since we've been in the theater
and [ __ ] like that so
me and the kids driving around me and
Josh and Liv driving around for the tour
right and so one day we were in uh
Oregon and I was like oh Gus fun sound
country they're like what are you
talking about and they're real film
heads the kids and [ __ ] they watch like
everything Liv is watching like the
British the BFI 100 and [ __ ] like their
greatest hunter film so the kids are
like really steeped in cinema but they
hadn't seen I was like oh [ __ ] we
should all blow people like in my own
private Idaho and they're like what are
you talking about I was like it's a
movie about male Hustlers you've never
seen them like no I was like [ __ ] Gus
Von son like no I was like what about
how do you [ __ ] not see my own
private Idaho man this is followed guys
follow up to [ __ ] Drugstore Cowboy
and they're like we never saw that
either what the [ __ ] man I was like we
gotta watch it and like and Liv's like I
put movies on the list we'll watch it I
was like I'm gonna watch it with you
when you guys watch it and then I was
like wait a second I was like just
[ __ ] watch it at the movie theater
man like one night while we're staying
here because I'm home for like four or
five days and [ __ ] we can run the movies
here at night and [ __ ] and Josh is like
I could hook that up and make that
[ __ ] happen so last night we came
down to watch my own private Idaho or
Drugstore Cowboy at nine o'clock at
night after the last show it was
Amsterdam or something we're like [ __ ]
off we chase people out close the
[ __ ] doors and [ __ ] like that but
then we realized that Disney plus
dropped werewolf by night yeah so we
said [ __ ] us fanson
[ __ ] the classic yes there's a Disney
plus thing we can watch in beautiful
black and white right stunning who makes
a movie in black and white I know it's
so old-timey
um Josh hooked it up and we watched it
was just the three of us in this [ __ ]
theater man I had a big tub full of fake
Meats vegan meats and [ __ ] I was like ah
my feet up I was wearing my pajamas and
[ __ ] like wow and I smoked [ __ ] weed
it was phenomenal man so phenomenal I
was worried the alarms would go off and
it didn't I was like I'm doing that
every night and [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
fantastic man and then at the end of it
I was talking to the kids kids that run
the theater are legit kids like [ __ ]
one of them plays field hockey and he
plays like there are high school kids
working for me and [ __ ] so the kids and
I were talking about Marvel movies and
[ __ ] and uh I think it was maybe Cooper
was just like uh oh [ __ ] Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 me and my dad watched
that [ __ ] he got mural emotional and I
was like that does have an emotional
ending and I was like Josh roll the last
20 minutes a [ __ ] Garden is a Galaxy
you're not gonna be able to be lived
with now oh I was like put it up on the
screen I'm gonna smoke weed and cry my
ass off and [ __ ] and he's like you're
weird I was like [ __ ] you and [ __ ] I
sat there and watched the last one it
was just blazing going [ __ ] yard oh
God
I'm gonna love living here yeah
oh God
that sounds great werewolf by night you
said you watched last night I did that's
[ __ ] fantastic that's great I was in
uh my motel room
watching infomercials drinking out of
this bottle
that's right that was the whole 10
minutes away I couldn't have made it
here
no I'm good
good I'm all good
we can I'm fine
I'm just fine
kids we're gonna run werewolf by night
again but you are I'll never watch that
goddamn movie now
on general principles it's [ __ ] great
I don't care it's really great it has
too many painful memories for me
just newly acquired painful memories
too many of them what time did you get
in uh I got in uh around seven o'clock
last night oh that was plenty of time
yeah plenty of time
scads of time so much time
you're good sorry they had a nice uh uh
a 25-inch TV I think in the room
probably this is similar to The
Experience you had I that's that's how I
welcome people to the jersey for the
first time by ignoring them and watching
TV
that's a very Jersey thing to do totally
yes
oh [ __ ] man I know you can come over now
we're moving on fair enough what are you
doing tonight you want to watch uh no
I'm busy
actually I am I don't know if there are
any garmy members in the audience here
tonight
love you guys uh we're doing a little uh
garmy meet up after this show for folks
who aren't sticking around for Tusk the
screening afterwards uh some garmy
members who are in town to watch us do
Babylon say well can we get together and
do a little meet and greet thing I was
like yeah we're gonna do that so after
we're done here meet me down at the
Harborside Grill I want to say I think
it's that way or is it that way it's
that way they say if you go out the
front door it's to the right say it's
real close and so I will be there and
make Beyond burgers
despite that I'll still be there
despite their fake meat
I'll be on hands if you want to come out
and say hi and take pictures or do
whatever and drink with me then that's
where I'll be please someone invite him
to watch werewolf no [ __ ] that
my friends and I are gonna be busy at a
bar so thanks for the invite but we're
good thanks so much
have you ever gotten drunken Jersey
before Oh
I grew up in Philadelphia
oh [ __ ] the only place would take my
fake ID was across the bridge
so you've gotten drunk here a lot yeah
that's what they tell me yeah but that's
like that's South Jersey what what does
that mean it's South Jersey
no no no Central Jersey
forgot where I was for a minute it's
real what
it's real
um doesn't Jersey aren't they all like
one big Kumbaya family or is it like no
no you [ __ ] nuts Jesus I've never
felt more like I was in Jersey until
that guy screamed [ __ ] that at me
I'm back on the East coaster with my
people yeah yeah
eight abides all right where was I oh
here we go shout outs we were in the
middle yeah
there may be no Tusk showing tonight I'm
just letting you know don't set up the
alarm on your way out because they may
have closed down the theater by the time
we're done
cops are gonna be like is that guy
taking a [ __ ] again
they're gonna come up with a code for
that
9702 emphasis on the two
uh Bridget Falk from Long Island are you
here Bridger brother Bridget Bridget uh
she's a hardcore Army member big Ralph
report to supporter thank you so much
she's been wanting you to come out here
more than me she's the reason one of the
reasons I'm here is her constant [ __ ]
badgering me
I kid you but she's like when are you
[ __ ] gonna go to [ __ ] Jersey and
do [ __ ] Hollywood [ __ ] Babylon
my God you sound like every woman in New
Jersey
she's from Long Island oh [ __ ] same diff
uh Bridget
's here with her boyfriend Chad Chad
Trujillo and they met via US through
Hollywood Babylon in the garmy and the
Ralph report and everything that's where
they've met each other is that right
so see kids you don't have to be alone
I was going Prima oh I see we get the
first shot is that what you're saying
not me you oh
um how long you guys been together now
a few months uh oh that's the good
[ __ ] time right there yeah yeah uh
Chad's a photo journalist with the Air
Force will be retiring next year after
20 years thank you for your service
thank you for your service what rank
what's right
E5 you sunk my battleship
sorry it's my it's my immediate reaction
sorry I don't know what E5 means yeah
what is it uh what is it staff sergeant
staff sergeant oh that's awesome that
was the first porn I ever made with
staff sergeant
I've heard that term in movies so that's
real yeah
Rachel says Chad is [ __ ] amazing it
makes me so incredibly [ __ ] happy she
really talks like this so I'm gonna skip
over some of the [ __ ] because we'll
be here all night Strong Island right
there uh to be [ __ ] honest I didn't
[ __ ] think I'd meet someone who could
make me so [ __ ] happy [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's not kidding I'm telling you it
looks like a Kevin Smith script laughs
since Princess Bride is one of our
favorite films I was really [ __ ]
hoping that we could have Al Pacino say
Inigo montoya's famous line sure of
course for You Bridget anything
hold on hold on
oh
Act
I've been on set with him this is really
what he does to people
hello
my name is a [ __ ] Montoya
not Tony Montana
you killed
my father
wow
prepare
two
die
there you go that's how well we're doing
[Applause]
speaking of experiences in this theater
Kevin yeah we got a call we got a an
email here from uh I'm gonna say Nick
and Sandra from Colt's neck are you guys
here Nick and Sandra
very excited to be here
what's going to happen to us yeah Don't
Clap too lousy
um Nick is here with his mom Sandra
bringing his mom to the show tonight uh
she has no idea why she's here however
oh oh she's not familiar with the show
oh I'm sorry but uh this is where nick
uh used to come to see the movies right
Nick yeah
when you were kids and so he's taking
her to dinner and date night out because
uh his dad has recently passed away and
so I'm so sorry it's a sun mom night out
which makes me very happy that's
beautiful makes me unhappy that she has
no idea while she's here
and she's very British by the way very
classy and very conservative
so our Target demographic yes exactly
um you must be baffled too like coming
to a movie theater and there's the
movie's live action
she obviously needs someone to warn her
says Nick too late yeah
my dad was a big fan of Hogan's Heroes I
was hoping the Germans could let her
know what's in store
yeah boy
poor Sandra yeah yeah yes isn't gonna
convince her anymore we can let Sandra
know what she's in store for the rest of
the night or not us of course but the
Germans could Josh
[Music]
no Nazis in New Jersey no
no they're all in New York
foreign
I think you're going to enjoy it yeah
welcome ma'am even though you're a
britisher remember the good old days
when we were enemies it's Greek ah yeah
don't drink tonight and get bombed
Sandra
it was for 1940s yes
too soon
when can we laugh at this
Logan's Heroes is like in the 60s
my God anyway it's a very entertaining
program there are lots of uh wholesome
uh jokes about uh poopy
your poopy and pee-pees and uh
um Liam Neeson has a huge card
we'll get into that later but it's a
that's a setup kids love it Sandra I
know it might not be a grown-up material
but uh oh [ __ ]
I'm embarrassed now I think Sandra
walked out
I'll read this episode
um I just want to take the Pulse Sandra
can you hear me say yes
you don't sound British
you oh I heard that that one was
um for somebody who's a complete version
of the show how are we doing so far
wow look at that that [ __ ]
we might have a brand new audience and
the the level of enthusiasm for a
British person say I'm enjoying it very
much it's like oh my God that's amazing
very reserved yeah yeah that's awesome
welcome Sandra we'll be checking in with
you throughout the evening yes just just
at any point we lose you raise your hand
be like I'm sorry uh the show stopped
being good
thank you
Carol Timonium
hi Carol
see that's how it's done Sandra yeah
so next time we call you I want to hear
uh Carol's here she's attending the show
with her cousin Dave his wife tally and
some of Dave's friends who don't
who don't rank who don't rank their
names being put in the email and the
rest
three of us are representing Ralph's
Hometown area of Northeast Philly we're
in we're in Northeast Philly
I went to Northeast High yeah
red line I know it well Somerton up
there yeah
yeah all these people are here I got
carried away
our families had a really rough year
says Carol I was hoping you would do a
segment you used to do years ago I
wondered if I could hear Pee-wee Herman
do the Ezekiel 25 17 speech from Pulp
Fiction
I'm shooting that [ __ ] that'll make your
day it'll make your year better will it
really
all right
the path of the righteous man could be
sat on all sides by the inequities of
the selfish and the tyranny of evil men
blessed is he you're in the name of
Charity and Goodwill Shepherds the weak
through the valley of the darkness
so dark
for he is truly his brother's keeper and
the finder have lost children where are
they
excellent ad-lib thank you
and I will strike down upon thee with a
great vengeance
and Furious anger those who attempt to
poison and destroy my brothers
and you will know my name is the Lord
there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
that hurts the throat
hey guys yeah uh Ernie needs to present
you with something he's trying to throw
the show off the rails oh oh Jesus what
happened
that's for Ralph
thank you
what is it
why Christmas comes early in Jersey yeah
doers white label Scotch thank you
all right glad we did that Ernie oh well
there's a oh there's another note okay
don't drink this it's poison
by the time you read this I will be dead
it would be too late if you touch the
bottle the Poison's already making its
way into your skin
uh can I bribe us a last minute shout
out Greg and Theresa is that correct
all right I just want to uh from
Worcester Massachusetts
yeah or Worchester as we say here in
Jersey yeah
um we are celebrating our 11-year
wedding anniversary on October 30th give
it up for the kids
foreign
[ __ ] for 11 years
um could jackpot the clown oh geez
free character from the Ralph report can
he freak out Kevin love you and love you
and mean it
bye what a great sign off that's the
sign off of the Ralph report
that's our that's our sign off oh my God
I showed my ignorance I'm like I'm a
huge fan I didn't know that
um Greg and Theresa gingold uh Summer's
over Brown drinks also a thing from the
show yeah I usually drink clear Liquors
in the summertime and then in the fall
and winter I'd go back to my brown
drinks look at you like and these people
know they know the whole show it's very
important all right so they're they give
them give them what they want I'll give
them what they want
uh jackpot the clown Greg and Theresa
yeah from oh did you guys drive here
from Mass
what the [ __ ] does that mean
sounds Shifty as [ __ ] Greg kind of we
teleported don't ask kinda we had a we
had to bury a body so it was
on the way we drove most of the way and
then we [ __ ] walked through the woods
to get here
all right jackpot the kick count
freaking Kevin out you know I'll do it
I'll freak you out I'll do the old
school uh putting the makeup on there
little creepy clown what's jackpot I'll
do his jackpot jackpot is a clown who
shows up periodically on my [ __ ] it's a
long story
do you have a bit a running bit I have a
running bit yes so here's jackpot
putting on his makeup okay
oh [ __ ] stop
you went so high to begin with
that was terrifying oh [ __ ] Pennywise
holy [ __ ]
that's not from an adult mouth that was
really disturbing
jackpot is go ahead try again
oh [ __ ] I gotta shoot this
shut up
[Music]
[Music]
it's awful right
happy anniversary kids
It's gotta hurt the [ __ ] voice I'm
not gonna make it
don't you sometimes just want a club
that Kevin Smith well how about instead
you join that Kevin Smith Club there are
so many ways into that Kevin Smith Club
ladies and gentlemen you don't have to
come through the front door you can come
through the back door we like it that
way sign up as a clerk where you get
access to all the audio that we got or
join as a mall rap that gives you all
the audio and all the video as well or
join as a fun ployee ladies and
gentlemen you'll get a new t-shirt an
exclusive that Kevin Smith Club t-shirt
every quarter or join as a yoga hoser
and get yourself something cool like a
back Kevin Smith wake and bake bowl for
2022 we've added some levels including
the fashionable able mail you get
everything that the clerk the mall rat
the yoga hoser and the fun employee gets
but you also get once a year an
exclusive piece of Wardrobe from a Kevin
Smith film or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mallrat the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got Untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house I
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bake and it
goes up on smodcast join us that Kevin
smithclub.com be a clerk be a mall rep
be a fun employee be a yogos or be a
fashionable male be a ranger danger or
be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
I'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that Kevin Smith club
and lastly Marco and Danny are you guys
in the hizzy does the kids say hey there
guys how are you my name is Marco my
wife's name is Danny we're driving up
from Georgia holy [ __ ] you drove from
Georgia hopefully you're doing other
things
oh good okay
I'm both happy and disappointed yeah all
right by that answer a second I was like
oh it's just us no it's not just us my
wife and I are childhood sweethearts
excuse me high school sweethearts and
we've been
high school high school I'd have to take
it further back High School's not long
enough you're like I'm gonna take it to
the [ __ ] kindergarten
I'm I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] this draft the
second draft
they knew each other in utero
uh High School sweethearts we've been
together for eight years married for
three I love her so much oh my God
somebody's getting laid tonight
and it would really make her night of
David Bowie could sing her happy
birthday tonight for her 27th birthday
oh happy birthday 27.
I would love to do that if I hadn't done
jackpot the clown just moments ago no
we'll give you a little put some liquor
down yeah that always helps
I light it on fire
all right Bowie 27th birthday we can do
this Josh
happy birthday to you Daddy
[Music]
you've been alive for
27 years happy birthday to you Danny
we're so happy to sell love great with
you happy birthday to you Daddy hey come
on
Jesus happy Birthday Danny
sorry I got a little on you
I guess back in the motel last night
they don't call it the hub for nothing
let's now
take a look at emails we get from all
around the world Josh
got an email man
featuring Kevin's reactions that's right
uh sadly Chas and Gianna rakita could
not be with us tonight but it's for the
most Charming of reasons they wrote
congratulations Kevin on the new theater
my fiance and I are huge fans of both
you and Ralph I'm a two-star general in
the garmy thank you guys we are from
Monmouth County they're very local read
their names again uh Chas and Gianna
sounds so [ __ ] Jersey
um what's the last name rakita
definitely [ __ ] Jersey
we wanted to come to the show tonight
but we're busy at the moment of the show
we are attending our own wedding
we're getting married tonight so they
couldn't be here he sent us an email to
wish as well how sweet is that kind of
sweet that we're on their minds not a
good sign for their marriage but still
we were actually thinking about sneaking
out and heading up from Howell to the
theater to see you guys but I was shot
down says Chas by almost everyone
I wonder who didn't shoot him down I
hope everything is great the show will
be awesome as always we'll enjoy it
later we hope that Babylon comes back
soon attaches a pic of us from the first
time we got to meet Kevin in 2019 that
my wife wanted me to send good you're
doing exactly what she tells you to do
Chaz you're off to an excellent yeah
really uh lmb guys and here is Chaz and
Gianna from the first time they met you
getting married tonight
I hope you're getting married in that
we called each other and said let's wear
our Silent Bob shirt that's right so I
wanted to give them a special mention
because they're adorable uh this is from
Reuben in Boston he writes dear Ralph
and Kevin today my cashier at Starbucks
was named Amy however I just can't get
past the way she spells it am I an
[ __ ] or is she an [ __ ] Reuben in
Boston well let's see how she spells Amy
I don't know
oh I me it's her it's her Reuben you're
off the hook
[ __ ] I me
it's Amy she spends her whole [ __ ]
life telling people it's Amy [ __ ]
spell it Amy
everyone will know I need
all right I need to get it off my chest
uh Dan Ruiz writes from Riverside
California back uh back in my old home
yeah would you please have oh I know
this guy now would you please have Jerry
Lewis sing they're coming to take me
away haha this is his [ __ ] now this has
become a new recurring segment where uh
someone asks me to sing they're coming
to take me away the old novelty song in
a variety of voices uh Dan would like to
hear it as Jerry Lewis
I'll do my best give me a little music
there Josh
[Music]
do not believe because I go berserk hi
you left me anyhow and then the days got
worse and worse and well you see I'm
going completely out of my mind hi
they're coming to take me away they're
coming to take me away
Life is Beautiful all the time and I'll
be happy to see those nice young men in
the clean white house and are coming to
take me away
all right there we go
foreign
folks in their travels run across town
to [ __ ] up names and they send them to
us we never got around to coming up with
a clever name for this segment so we
just call it your Town's got a [ __ ] up
name
sounds like I'm still doing Jerry Lewis
I said when I was in England in Essex I
ran across this town I thought you guys
would appreciate it so they sent a sign
in
welcome to
fingering hoe
fingering hoe England
I bet there's some fingering hoe what's
been going on in this theater over the
years
wait hey no no in the best sense uh
fingering hoe man that's the [ __ ]
place I'd like to live me too yeah
right next to [ __ ] stroke England right
now
we also get emails from folks who find
things that are meant for kids but turns
out they're inappropriate toys
appropriate for girls not appropriate
for boys what the [ __ ] is that
inappropriate toys
first one comes from Jason NATO from
Lincoln Nebraska he said apparently this
item is designed to celebrate the
thriving Metropolis that is coming
Georgia it's a game that the whole
family can play can we take a look Josh
coming up police
my favorite one go coming
oh coming
and then 200 exchanges and suddenly I
get money and I'm like wow
uh Cody Kelly wrote this one in from
Traverse City Michigan
um this is a retro toy he ran across and
he thinks maybe it's inappropriate it's
uh wrestlers WWF wrestlers from the
1980s the kids are supposed to wrestle
with but uh well you look at the picture
you see how your kids are supposed to
wear them you stick your thumb up the
ass of your wrestler
of the Iron Sheik and Hulk Hogan yeah
somebody's got their thumb right up Hulk
Hogan's [ __ ] he could take it all
look at that [ __ ] I don't know I think
it I think it takes its toll if you look
at the next picture I think these
wrestlers
let that be a warning kiss knock the
bottom out holy [ __ ] anal anal can be
damaging if done too often that's a PSA
the more you know yeah
um Josh Gilmore sent this one in from
Hesperia California these are uh rides
the kids go on outside they used to be
outside like um department stores and
grocery stores yeah
uh this one
you have no idea how right you are let's
take a look at Donald Duck here
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you're literally holding on to
the handlebars you are riding Donald
Duck cowgirl style
best case scenario maybe he's giving you
a [ __ ] while it's going on but Andy's
got no pants on and he's well of course
I gotta be ready at any time if you're
that dust
folks we have to say goodbye to some
people in Show Business who left us too
soon but left behind bodies of work that
we'll appreciate for a long time to come
we call them the Tinseltown stiffs and
now another edition of
so I'm still
they will be missed this one sucks I saw
this yesterday and this one actually
hurt I liked her when I was a kid I
loved her when I was a kid and she's
very specific to a certain time and
place in my life because I really
haven't seen much of her lately
apparently she kept performing but for a
minute she was just everywhere huge she
was the original girl geek we're talking
about Judy tenuna tenuta the comedian
the love goddess love goddess yeah uh
she used to play accordion on stage and
tell bizarre jokes and hurt it's called
men pigs yeah it was that era where
there was an explosion of comedy in the
80s where people were just doing Off the
Wall stuff emo Phillips and people like
that she was a very much of the uh Weird
Al Yankovic emo Phillips School of
Comedy Weird Al uh featured her in a
couple of his videos she also played
according as well they were very close
she passed away at the age of 72 this
week are you [ __ ] me yeah
so I'm 52 she was always 20 years older
than me yep she aged very well I saw a
picture of her like not too long ago and
she did not look [ __ ] 72 what'd she
die from how'd she passed uh cancer
sadly oh [ __ ] yeah I'm getting I'm
getting an ass full of cancer quite
frankly I'm tired of cancer I thought
you were telling me I'm not an ass full
of cancer I'm like Ralph it's not a
diagnosis no it's just I'm sort of fed
up with it I would like I would like
that to stop I know we're at the age
where that just starts happening to
people we know yeah and it and I don't I
don't care for it quite frankly I'm
going to go out on a limb here I know it
might be controversial so you're in
Jersey but I'm gonna say I'm against
cancer and I don't care how any of you
feel hot take everybody right the
internet's gonna come for us cancel me I
don't care I'm down with cancer when did
this happen oh a couple days ago you
didn't see this [ __ ] no oh Kevin I'm
sorry to break it to you oh my God I was
a huge fan as well anybody and here's
the thing I'm not a massive country
music fan but there's a yeah yeah
there's a certain percentage of artists
from the world country music that
transcend genre and this lady was one of
them Loretta Lynn has passed away at the
age of 90.
she was an icon
and an enormous Talent great songwriter
for herself yeah great songwriter great
singer of course from the movie Coal
Miner's Daughter a lot of people were
introduced to her through [ __ ] SpaceX
performance as Loretta Lynn but she was
never never rested on her Laurel she was
always creating she worked with um
Van Lear rose that whole album yeah I
mean just enormously talented what a
body of work too and 18 times she was
nominated for Grammys she won three 21
number one singles on the country's
charts 11 number one albums over the
course of her career which spammed I
don't know six decades it's crazy she
was a little girl from Butcher Holler
she was
um she uh married do little Lynn I mean
we all saw the movie Women not all if
you have never seen Coal Miner's
Daughter let's put it up on the screen
let's [ __ ] watch it
[Laughter]
look how young she is
[Music]
I love that too God she's fantastic
um
[Applause]
she wrote uh songs by herself she was
self-taught yes self-taughter uh on the
guitar and hit after hit after hit it
was kind as if she was a savant like it
was just sort of something she was born
with yeah and I've always loved that
song in particular because a lot of
country music was well someone stole my
man or stole my girl or whatever and she
was like [ __ ] you try to take my man I
will [ __ ] you up yes I was like what a
refreshing change from the average
country song
um here on the show we look at mistakes
in TV wait are we done with Loretta Lynn
no one else died this far as I know
unless you got somebody no I just it
feels like we can talk more about her
ten more minutes on her I I don't know
that's just my father [ __ ] loved
Loretta my mom loved her too did your
mom my dad used to like are we gonna are
we gonna battle now about yeah
[ __ ] who liked mark my dad would um
on the weekends he'd be in his room and
he had like a you know Hi-Fi stereo
played records and [ __ ] and he loved
country music in a big bad way and [ __ ]
and so he would throw on Loretta Lynn
and sing at the top of his month wow and
not high voice but just like as high as
he could go and stuff and I remember he
took us to see Coal Miner's Daughter six
times in the theater I saw that I know
that movie backwards and forwards one of
my favorite movies ever made and the
year that we got into the Library of
Congress with clerks as as uh on the um
uh National film registry right we went
in with Michael aptit's coal miners no
way and that was we went in with purple
rain and other movies as well but being
with Coal Miner's Daughter
alphabetically we were next to each
other but also as a movie that was so
[ __ ] important to my father and
became important to me because it was
important to him but then became
important to me later on because it's
the story of somebody from nowhere who
then takes the world stage right and
clearly later on in life there was a lot
of identity factor with that so much so
that at one point I got a bus because I
remember [ __ ] she had a bus in the
movie and [ __ ] and I was like yeah if
you're on the road and [ __ ] you got to
be in a bus I never got to meet her I've
met Dolly Parton but I never got to meet
[ __ ] Loretta Lynn man and I'll regret
it now forever 90 years old she was yeah
[ __ ] man give it up for the Coal Miner's
Daughter not a bad run but maybe it's
too soon for us yeah yeah
God damn it [ __ ] I gotta call my mother
my mom do you know [ __ ] Loretta Lynn
died she's like yeah it's been on all
the news Where Have You Been poor boy oh
yeah truly my head up my own ass Josh we
have a we have a problem are we good no
just Vamp for a second there we go I had
to change the battery no worries oh fair
enough whatever you need pal it's all
about you it's your world right
all we did was stroke you off all shawl
show man can I can we stroke off rash
one more time let's stroke him up so you
know I don't know if you guys know this
or not but I bought a movie theater
recently what some friends yeah I hate
to talk about it but it's true um uh one
of the things that allows you when you
buy a movie theater you own a movie
theater go on a movie theater is you can
start programming [ __ ] right so I've
come up with a bunch of [ __ ] like uh
Sure Shot movies that were just shot in
New Jersey
um [ __ ] Malcolm ingrams to do mad
Malcolm's [ __ ] uh movie jukebox so
all movie musicals and [ __ ] super cool
what will Ralph Garmin want to do what
will you want to program oh an Adam West
Film Festival
perfect
absolutely perfect but I came up with a
thing that I want to do so uh Josh and
Olivia Roush make the docs that Josh
particularly makes that he hates when I
give credit to other people
makes the docs like he made the dock for
the documentary for Tusk behind the
scenes doc he made the documentary for
Jay and Silent Bob reboot which is
Magnum dopas and he uh just made the one
that's on the clerk's three DVDs what do
you call them the clerk's three dock uh
the clerks three documentary
it's catchy I think people are gonna
like clever very clever Josh
um and he also has wrong reasons so
there's like four movies right there
plus he made this documentary about
Michael Parks
um which he's not working on forever
yeah he's because we're waiting for
Clinton to do an interview and stuff so
that gives you four minimum five movies
to show so um in when we were talking
about February March
live end of January we're going to have
a mini Film Festival
film festival called wait for it
rauschamon
[ __ ] you that's clever
that's the kind of thing you do man when
you got the movie theaters program a
festival of your friends stuff how dope
is that gonna be never made a yoga hoser
stock did you yeah I didn't think so
okay just checking
I was never contacted for an interview
or anything so I assumed that that one
didn't get a documentary no no that's
okay somebody tweeted today that they
just watched it and loved it so that
person said my response was see Kevin
that's that Kevin Smith I told you
there'd be somebody now if they just
paid 10 million to see it we'll be all
good we'd be in the black yeah
speaking of mistakes in movies and
television
I made a movie with my child you [ __ ]
and me yeah that's who I was talking
about don't
foreign
we like to find things that go wrong in
TV and movies because everyone else just
doesn't seem to care we call this
segment [ __ ] that should not be
[Music]
here's some [ __ ] that should not be
this comes in from Jim Weldon he says I
found this little nugget and it made
nope thank you I'm all good
careful
go on
found this little nugget and it made me
laugh it's from one of Kevin's favorite
actor Bruce Willis's best movies die
hard I pasted the link in the email
please note oh okay I know what he's
saying there's no [ __ ] that should not
be in Die Hard I thought the same until
Jim Weldon sent in this clip what is it
this is the lovely Alan Rickman
he didn't make the mistake
I wouldn't do that to you it's when the
corpse comes off the elevator and uh ho
ho ho ho ho ho ah no I have a machine
gun too yes do you know what I'm going
to talk about no guy's dead right the
guy in the chair is dead
dead men aren't supposed to Blink and
Flinch when you touch their face
ever in Die Hard well I'll just show you
now I have a machine gun okay watch his
right eye oh
oh
he's dead he's dead his eyes open
he's dead his eyes open because he's
doing oh he's dead and his eyes so yeah
you're not supposed to Flinch oh one of
the guy's getting paid leave your eye
open movies ruined oh movies are awful
and speaking of movies that get ruined
this is one of my favorites in a long
long time it's called exquisite
exquisite acting this is where we take a
look at an A-list playlist actor uh who
doesn't necessarily turn in an A-list
performance although I can't just single
one actor out in this scene because
everybody is just [ __ ] awful and
wonderful at the same time it is a from
a film from 1992. we forgot our theme
song I'm gonna get to it oh okay
it's a lot of shoe leather to get to the
[ __ ] theme song and Josh play the
theme song
to be or not to be that is the question
welcome to the world of Exquisite acting
with Ralph Garman and Kevin Smith all
right
1992 films called Live Wire featuring
Pierce Brosnan oh I know that movie yeah
what yeah from rst video we have three
copies and I was like why did you get
three copies of live wives I had never
heard of this movie until this very show
it's [ __ ] nuts
I [ __ ] you not here's Brosnan plays a
demolition expert who's called in
because someone blew up a senator and
they can't figure out how and it turns
out some terrorist has figured out how
to create an explosive that people
swallow and stomach acid makes them
human bombs
you must not have heard me they swallow
it and they become human bombs
what the sweet glorious [ __ ] is that all
about
you must not have hurt me so Pierce
Brosnan rides around this whole movie
trying to keep people's stomachs from
blowing up because they explode
their stomachs explode I don't know if
you're listening so it's [ __ ] Tums
the movie exactly
no Dynamite no nothing just tummy
blowing up
anyway in this particular scene there's
a clown at a kid's birthday party oh
[ __ ]
who I guess has been fed the magic boom
boom juice
and and Pierce Brosnan [ __ ] you just
watched yes
[Applause]
I'm coming
[Applause]
come on
Josh live you know we're watching
tonight
Live Wire I don't know what I'll be
watching in my room but you guys enjoy
that that sounds like fun
oh that [ __ ] rocked come on down I
say remake remake
Christopher Nolan's Live Wire it's
perfect as it is all right time now to
take a look at the world of
entertainment news in a segment we call
the HBO headlines
[Music]
oh
geez it happens when you're good at it
you all right he's [ __ ] meow yes
you're insured right this place is
insured at least I got hurt I can't even
sue the [ __ ] I know that's what I'm
thinking
so I can [ __ ] Sue
this was a shocking piece of news some
folks were at a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
competition last week and in walks to
compete Tom Hardy
see Tom Hardy one lady likes that either
loves Jiu Jitsu or Tom Hardy the Tom
Hardy shows up not as a celebrity guest
or a judge or anything just signs up to
compete in the tournament he wants to
fight yes he's a fighter he's a jiu
jitsu fighter he's got a blue belt I
didn't know any of this until this story
came out do you imagine you're [ __ ]
like hey man we're fighting all of a
sudden he's like I'll come to kick you
off
please step to the side
I can hurt you with a glance more
importantly he won the gold medal at the
tournament what the 2022
umac Brazilian Jiu Jitsu open
championships last Saturday a week ago
he walked on signed up and won the gold
he's for real yo
could you it sucks that he's good at so
many things that's my point pick a lane
[ __ ] he's 45. what 45 years old
I thought it was way younger me too I
mean it looks so [ __ ] good yeah and
he's great as an actor and he can kill
me with his thighs or whatever Jiu Jitsu
is
oh him killing me with my thighs yeah
now I know what I'm gonna do tonight in
my hotel room
I shall kill you with my thighs Ralph
Carmen
when I asked lies and Ashes
then you can die
he put a statement on his Instagram
account after the win he said well why
am I saying it let's let Tom Hardy read
it for himself simple training for me as
a hobby in the private love has been
fundamentally key to further develop the
deepest sense of inner resilience
calm and well-being I can't stress the
importance of God to the impact on my
life and my fellow teammates
there you go so congratulations Tom
Hardy who apparently is good at
everything is there a photo yeah we got
a picture of him uh out there on the on
the mat getting [ __ ] done oh my God he
looks like he's in the Revenant
he looks terrifying yeah look at that
[ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] with Tom Hardy
uh Paris Hilton would like to send
everybody a message tonight she didn't
contact me personally it's to everyone
came from Hollywood you brought a
message from Hollywood
I just got in Paris Hilton asked me
something to tell you
she uh her dog is missing her dog
Diamond baby is missing that's the name
Diamond I'm in babies the name of the
dog I don't know so when we're out in
public we'd be like here Diamond baby
just screaming all night time it baby
it's a Chihuahua match and um if you
have any information go to find
diamondbaby.com now some folks have said
that dog may have been taken off by a
coyote because there are a lot of those
in California but she says no because
she has been assured by the very best
pet psychics that the dog is still alive
fair enough so rest assured she's only
gone to the very best pet psychics not
the [ __ ]
which are all of the pet psychics
[ __ ] clown shoes man I got it that
dog was gonna open a pet psychic shop
that seems like he's that's what real
money is yeah your dog's fine your pet's
still alive and he misses you a lot he
loves that when you do that thing what's
that thing you do scratch his back yes
that's the one that's the thing
uh Community movies happening over a
peacock oh Community fans in the house
how many seats six seasons six scenes in
a movie that was their chance and now
it's all coming true uh shockingly
however it says here Chevy Chase not
returning oh that's surprising yeah but
kills his character off to make sure
that would never happen Dan is coming
back is Dan Harmon doing it yeah Dan
Harmon's on board Joe McHale Danny putty
uh Allison Brie Jillian Jacobs Jim Rash
Ken Jeong are all signed on they say
although Donald Glover and Yvette Nicole
Brown probably won't have big roles
though probably for Cameo good for them
here's something I don't think we need
Sony has announced another Tarzan movie
in the works
we don't need another Tarzan look any
character in the right hands could be
compelling but like [ __ ] who cares at
this point man like we got Marvel
characters and [ __ ] put on your [ __ ]
clothes this character was created at
the turn of the 20th century in the
early 1900s it was fascinating to
imagine a man being raised in the jungle
and being discovered because no one knew
he was there I get it not gonna happen
now no and they say they want to update
it to make a 21st century story about
Tarzan which is even dumber because we
would find him on Google view or
whatever
you see a little guy swinging from tree
to tree if he just Googled jungle then
you'd see it on the on the screen hey
he's alive after all exactly yes so
they're announcing they're going to
re-re I think the last one they did was
with uh what's his [ __ ] Skarsgard oh God
yeah right yeah he's [ __ ] dreams
that's a Tarzan I would [ __ ] no doubt
let's be honest that's a Tarzan who
would [ __ ] me yeah he'd be swinging from
his Vine oh God yes be like oh
Eugene
you Tarzan me hungry for dick
[Laughter]
just like it was written by Edgar Rice
Burroughs himself
well you got to keep it simple for the
eight man to understand well we wanted
to update it right 2022 that's how you
do it man
oh mate James dude having to be a gay
Tarzan there it is now I'm watching yeah
yeah in fact I think I have watched that
I think there was a video on PornHub I
may have taken a glance at it the
subcategory the glance Tarzan guy on
guys I was exploring
now I'm curious to know how you feel
about this Kevin being a biggest fan of
this program as you are Paramount plus
has announced a sequel to Frasier Kelsey
Grammer coming back with his beloved
character Frasier Crane to another TV
series and David Hyde Pierce no word yet
on who will be joining him however again
they say likely cameos if not co-stars
but Frazier is moving to a brand new
city he won't be in uh Seattle in
Seattle yeah so it's a brand new start
for Frasier so perhaps a brand new
Supporting Cast
um I'm for Frasier I'm all for it but
Kelsey Grammar turned out to be kind of
trumpy and stuff yeah and kind of lost
my interest yeah so yeah I probably
won't watch it I think the show was so
well done very well done I think it's
kind of stands alone I don't know if we
need to go back to that well or not but
I mean again in the right hands it could
be fantastic but uh I you know I
interviewed him once at the [ __ ] uh
Aspen Comedy Fest and he was the least
[ __ ] funny person I've ever
interviewed in my life really yeah it
was like me and Annie mcelfresh and Andy
was writing for The Tonight Show so Andy
would like to feed me questions and
stuff and you know since Andy was like
well Kevin's asking the questions some
of the questions are like really like
[ __ ] like so are you done drunk
driving or what oh my God I'm not
Stuttering John I can't [ __ ] go for
the kill like this
so I went in and tried to like first
approach about like I'm a big fan of
Frasier and he's just like uh-huh uh he
was very not having it and [ __ ] and he
was married to the one who was on that
TV show oh yeah I can't remember she was
a real housewife a Camille or something
like that oh come here I forgot six yes
he uh at one point um I made I read one
of Andy's jokes I forget what it was but
it was it was a kind of groaner but he
[ __ ] looked at Camille and he goes
do you see what I have to deal with no
yes yes it was so [ __ ] weird and I
was like all right we're gonna kill this
bit right here and he was like thank you
and [ __ ] [ __ ] off wow yeah so [ __ ]
him I'm watching that I guess not
he can toss your salad and scramble your
eggs
well done thank you so much
and he wrote that theme song and sang
that theme I know he said I didn't know
that he wrote it he wrote some of it
yeah this must be a little cha-ching in
his pocket every time yeah he got paid
yep and uh Velma from Scooby-Doo was in
the news this week she has come out it's
Canon now that Velma is actually lesbian
everyone's very excited and for me for
years that's what I thought didn't we
all sort of agree we all agreed to it in
the [ __ ] 70s man yeah and uh but
apparently in the newest Scooby-Doo
movie she gets a crush on a girl and
yada yada and some people are upset [ __ ]
them
no really if you're if you're concerned
about a cartoon character's sex life
just [ __ ] check out you got nothing
left there's just there's nothing else
in your life that can concern you
because that's your focus I don't I got
nothing for you I love the poor girl eat
her Scooby Snacks right yes
like zoinks man
it's like zoinks velma's [ __ ] a chick
yeah
Daphne and Fred hucking it out from the
side and [ __ ] I'm waiting for Fred to
come out of the closet that's what I'm
waiting for just cause a guy wears
Necker chips I'm just saying a little
too good pretty for me I think yeah you
think so yeah pulls off a mask
it's him it's him under the mask
and I would have got away for it if it
weren't for you meddling kids
every episode we got to check in with
this Canadian douchebag
I wonder who that is because people
demand it
time for some Justin Bieber news
[Music]
goddamn right
from time to time I get an opportunity
to announce some good Justin Bieber
music and this is one of those shows
Justin Bieber has announced the
cancellation of the remainder of his
world oh [ __ ] through 2023. yes what
happened
well Kevin he's tired oh I feel bad he's
exhausted did he shoot a music video
into a podcast as well no he just goes
out on stage and sort of sings every
night and sort of dances and he said
it's just all too much not only for his
physical well-being but his mental
health as well so all the remainder of
the tours this tour kicked off back in
February uh still upcoming dates in the
UK Ireland Germany Italy Poland the
Netherlands and other countries have all
been spared by the Lord Jesus
hahaha
truly an act of God it really is yes uh
he said he needs to take the time off
for his mental and physical health needs
some healing because it's just can you
imagine working for a living going out
on stage and talking to people and
singing oh my God sounds like a lot of
work a horror it's a horror Kevin as
opposed to I don't know Roofing or
hanging drywall or putting in plumbing
or doing a [ __ ] job truly
[ __ ] Justin Bieber so much
can we play that theme one more time I
just need that to get out of my system
thank you so much
[Music]
I'll tell you why because you're a
little [ __ ] Justin Bieber
and I know you listen
they're talking about me again
jerks
hey we got some Geeks in the house
anybody a geek
good it's time for the geek news
[Music]
this one is a personal question for me
to you because I haven't had a chance to
talk to you since the trailer dropped
yes black panther too did you watch that
trailer what kind of forever trailer
what kind of forever looks amazing right
that's fantastic okay that's all I
wanted to talk about moving on I haven't
had a chance to have a conversation with
him while he's been co-signed it does it
looks it's going to make easily a
billion if not two billion easily right
looks Dynamic [ __ ] the more man yeah
and he's got Wings on his feet I know
they saw him in that one trailer he's
like he flies with the wings on his feet
right so [ __ ] metal what's his hat
all about though what's that hat he's
wearing because they're uh they based it
more on the was it a Mesozoic or the
um Latin American uh I got you I'm
taking it from like Mexico or something
like that which nemour was always kind
of nebulous right we did so now they
were like look let's give him a [ __ ]
identity and we could tie it I think
they're tying in yeah
okay and his God versus the Black
Panther God very cool thing yeah it
looks [ __ ] Wicked Man and there's
also rumor that killmonger is in it as
well really yeah how how that would work
I don't know but
some I saw somebody online again this is
just conjecture online but like remember
he was like throw me into the ocean
right
the submariners who lives in the ocean
yeah
[Music]
well it may be flipperal making it be
amazing holy [ __ ]
kilogor on his back my God that's nine
Impressions you're a son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] a flipper as well who knew
you've been holding that for 12 years
I got lots of tricks up my sleeve Hallie
keeping it fresh
um they found a new way to get more
money from us I'm so glad Hasbro has
announced they are re-releasing the
Indiana Jones action figures do you
remember these when you're [ __ ]
Kenner version let's throw the picture
up Josh they're gonna really have these
the OG Indiana Jones Kenner version
hasbros announced they are re-releasing
those so that man children everywhere
it's this time you paid I'm throughout
the old one but no one's taken this one
guys can we throw that up again
perfect likeness
right looks more like me than it does
Harrison Ford
I wonder what that would sound like
um
and then I'm traveling a plastic bottle
are you trapped in the bubble yeah I'm
stuck in the middle
bellock
[Laughter]
pennyworth is a show apparently yeah
about Alfred yes what did anyone tell me
about this yeah yeah they're up to like
nine Seasons or something they start in
the 50s apparently yes it was in black
and white and now it's still on
television for a while no but it's on
epics yeah and it's been running for a
while but at least three seasons I think
I think it is three seasons the creators
are very happy because it's being moved
to HBO Max oh could you imagine you were
on epics and suddenly somebody's like
you're gonna be HBO Max like whose dick
do I got a sock like oh that's what the
producer says Bruce uh Bruno Heller by
the way who's also the guy who did he
did uh Gotham yes and he also wrote yes
which I [ __ ] love and he also did
uh The Mentalist I think it was no was
it the Mentalist oh the TV show yeah
that guy with that good looking blonde
guy who yeah
confidential yeah him that's him too he
did that show yeah guy Heller is busy as
hell cranks out some shows yeah he's
thrilled by the way that they're no
longer going to be on epics because as
you can tell no one knows what happens
yeah really [ __ ] HBO Max is picking up
the reruns and we'll have the brand new
uh fourth I guess season it is on that
show as well on that uh streaming
service however he he like Likens it to
being on a grocery
store shelf he said we've just been put
next to the Frosted Flakes he said if
you're a cereal you don't want to be in
way in the back with the bargain Brands
you want to be up next to the big name
so he's excited that they're going to be
I'm sure epics feels great about that
yes I hope he never has another show to
pitch to epics I feel like we're toasted
oats we're not even Cheerios [ __ ] you
at Christian Bell in an interview this
week announced the one Star Wars
character that would persuade him to
join the franchise all right can I try
to guess sure Admiral thrawn nope really
um
I give up he wants to play the storm
trooper that hits his head on the
doorway in a new hope that's the only
character he says that interests him
if I was [ __ ] Disney I'd be like fine
let's do it I would make a whole [ __ ]
series just to [ __ ] him over just to be
like get in the suit [ __ ]
so it's 10 episodes about you hitting
your [ __ ] head no it happens
afterwards after he hit his head like do
you have some aspirin
oh good for you you worked all day
making food I hit my head on a doorway
doing the work of the Empire
and then I hit my [ __ ] head are you
not professional you are the
Stormtroopers who are supposed to wash
my head it's just him screaming for an
entire series Perfection yes
um what a Wise Acre he is man he's he's
he's he's a he's a jokester he's fun he
said all I ever wanted in Star Wars was
to be in a Star Wars stormtrooper outfit
and hit my head on the door or something
as I walk through low bar
literally that's how he hit his head yes
all right folks it's almost time to say
good night but we got one last bit of
business before we do oh my God this is
uh Sandra how you holding up
good
I thought we might have lost her uh you
still with us Sandra
how about how about a review
or not [ __ ] you that was the review was
that it the silence I see
say again
good impression Impressions Impressions
plural me too
why thank you Sandra
um Hardy right I got one thing man yeah
I'm sorry he's good too his flipper
right
um
but coming from England was that Tom
Hardy pretty good
like for a second we were like he might
be from England too and then you were
like oh he's he's alive he's having a
laugh
if she was that just cured her
oh
uh thank you Sandra I'm gonna [ __ ]
talk to my mother tomorrow morning and
be like a lady from England said I was
good at Impressions mom
so be like tiger you had that dream
again
before we say good night Sandra there's
a there's a recurring thing we do here
on the show we mentioned it at the top
the Germans brought it up to you uh Liam
Neeson you're familiar with the Liam
Neeson the actor remember we planted a
seed yeah this is where it sprouts yes
Fred Groves Sandra
Liam Neeson the Irish actor I don't know
if you're familiar with this or not
Sandra it's it's fairly common knowledge
that he has an enormous
penis let's say
famously live we're not talking a
Celsius can we're talking [ __ ] maybe
like a Jack Daniels bottle
not Square don't get me I mean he's not
weird we don't know it could be but
[ __ ] it's thick as a dick
so that topic came on early on in this
show that we started like a decade ago
and so ever since then people have been
sending in their factoids about how big
his penis in so is rather and so toxic
Sandra dude I know but you got to break
her in all right
so they send in facts about how big his
[ __ ] is
and that's how we sort of say good night
is like we we say good night with this
last segment so we're going to talk
talking about how big Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is
the
introduce right
and that's in another language did he
onboard you properly do you understand
what's about to happen Sandra
yes
I probably overdid it you probably did
are you sure you want to stay
she said I can't get out now I have to
climb over too many people Sandra you've
been thinking about this for an hour
haven't you she's been kissing the joint
people to the left of me people to the
right of me here I am not leave here I
am stuck in the middle with my son
I'm sorry Sandra that was the worst Tom
Hardy ever
and that flipper what the [ __ ]
but the Christian Bell was funny yes
yeah oh [ __ ] that was pretty good wasn't
his Christian Bell pretty British did
that work for you
I tried buddy okay I appreciate it
all right Sandra fair enough Buckle in
here's a whole bunch of [ __ ] jokes
coming at you
it's too late now
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
he's the new Sensei at Cobra Kai dojo
current Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
the FBI raided it looking for classified
documents
planted planted in his [ __ ]
Declassified all of them with a wave
Liam nice [ __ ] is so big
he's officially next in line for the
throne of England you'd appreciate that
one ever since uh Queen Elizabeth passed
away he's next up Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big
it has a blue belt in the ancient
martial art of
jujitsu
[Applause]
take that Tom Hardy it's very different
and lastly Lee Mason's [ __ ] is so big
it just bought its hometown's movie
theater
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen of Atlantic
Highlands if you had a good time this
evening
thank you so much for being here with us
what a very special night thank you
thanks for coming to Smart Castle
Cinemas but there would be no show
tonight without the bands about left
give it up for Ralph [ __ ] Garmin
let's hear it for my bestest Babel
brother Mr Kevin Smith
and that is Hollywood Babylon for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
Bobble the [ __ ] off good night New
Jersey
give it up for Ralph garment and Kevin
Smith
foreign
[Music]
greetings everybody and welcome to the
AKA ask Kevin every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]